We just use some basic SQL to pull out one link.
It had a where clause that looked something like this.
Let's talk about how we can make this a little bit fancier.
Instead of just saying ID = 2, let's change this constraint a little bit.
I've changed the clause to be instead of ID = something
to submitter ID = 5.
Okay, so I've added an and clause.
Select * from links where submitter ID = 5 and votes > 23.
And this is a perfectly legit SQL query, and it will also be even more expressive.
We could change this a little bit even more.
We could change this and to an or, for example,
and this would return us all of the links that were submitted by user 5
or all of the links who have more than 23 votes,
and so you can see SQL is fairly expressive, and you can use and and or,
and you can use equals and greater than or equal to
and less than and all sorts of cool stuff.
And already you can see we can ask fairly sophisticated questions of our database.